[Music]
we're gonna be talking about firestore
today my name is natalie vase and i'm a
product manager on cloud firestore I
will be joined by my colleague Ben
Whitehead who's on our developer
relations team and he will come on stage
later on in the presentation so first I
wanted to start with a quick overview of
this session so the main goal of this
session is for you to walk away
understanding what firestore is what
it's good for and how you can integrate
it with other parts of the GCP ecosystem
for those of you who are new to the
product I'm going to start with an
introduction and a history of the
product I'll highlight some of the new
product announcements that we made this
year as going as part of going generally
available in January I'll walk through
some of our example customer
architectures of people that are using
this in production today and then
finally I'll give it over to Ben who
will walk you through a demo
demonstrating firestore in action we'll
also leave some time at the end of the
session for Q&A and speaking of QA how
we're actually going to do it in this
session today is using an application
called Dory
which we use internally at Google to
manage Q&A at scale you can actually
find this through your next mobile
application for this session this will
allow you to submit questions throughout
the period of this session and you can
upvote and downvote other people's and
I'll be using that to moderate at the
end of the session so please feel free
to check that out so let's go ahead and
dive into an introduction to firestore
Before we jump into that I'd like to get
a bit of a sense of the audience we have
today how many of you out there have
actually used fyrst already that's
awesome looks like 40% how about the
real-time database firebase real-time
database okay less of you and how about
cloud datastore cool sounds good that's
good background for the session so cloud
firestore is one of many database
offerings that we have within Google's
cloud portfolio here you can see a list
of all of the managed
database services cloud firestore is our
no sequel documented document-oriented
database making it part of our
non-relational offering and we'll talk
about this data model a little bit later
in the presentation I want to take a
step back briefly and imagine that
you're trying to build a mobile app for
your company if you're starting a
project from scratch and you want to
build it yourself
you're likely gonna have to think about
a couple of things number one setting up
a database which you'll probably have to
run and scale yourself if you're taking
something off the shelf in front of that
you'll need to put some sort of API
layer that can make queries from your
clients that probably means also adding
an authentication layer so that you can
make sure that users that are accessing
your data are authenticated and this
also means adding some sort of sync
logic so that you can make sure make
sure your data is syncing with the local
results and finally these local results
are probably going to be stored in a
completely separate client database that
again you have to make sure is syncing
with your database that we mentioned up
at the front now when you arrive here
all of a sudden you have a pretty
complex set of solutions each of these
as a standalone could actually be a
whole company in itself and that's a
week we actually see today is that
people are going to go to many vendors
many different places to actually
accomplish this stack to build their
mobile or web apps and this is why we
built fire store fire store was built to
tackle these problems that are very
common to mobile and web app development
and to simplify this process for you for
those that are familiar with cloud
datastore and the firebase real time
database an important question is how
does this relate to those cloud
firestore is the next generation of
cloud datastore and it includes
important learnings from the firebase
real time database so we took a look at
the developer wish lists from each of
these and we use those to inform the
decisions that we made when building
cloud fire store so you can think of
this as the best of both worlds it takes
some of the best elements of datastore
and some
the best elements and learnings from
firebase real-time database the first
thing to know is that firestore is fully
supported in the firebase SDKs this
includes web iOS and Android so you can
access data directly from the clients
this is actually pretty unusual for a
database and it's not lost on us that
letting letting clients talk directly to
your database can pose all sorts of
challenges for one you can't always
trust the data that's coming from
clients and secondly you're dealing with
potentially unauthorized users
so this is where firebase auth and
security rules come in handy these allow
you to validate operations from the
client and this removes the need to
build that middle tier that you saw in
the previous slide which can sometimes
be its own standalone server just to
manage authentication now the next thing
that's very important is the ability to
have these applications work across
multiple devices when we're talking
about client access maybe you put down
your phone you walk over to your desktop
computer and you expect to resume the
same state in your app that you're
operating on so this is something that
firestore handles natively and it makes
it really really great for those
applications that you want to develop
and serve to multiple types of devices
at one time now another problem that's
very very common these days is people
expect their apps to work offline it's
fairly normal for people to look at
their mobile applications when there's
little to no chance of connectivity
maybe you're running through the airport
you're at the top of a mountain or maybe
you've gone offline on purpose so the
same technology that allows us to
operate in offline mode also helps in
those situations where we have spotty
network connection and so as you can
imagine this is very challenging to
solve and we've actually built this
natively into firestore it requires
building complex sync and conflict
resolution logic on the client so in
cloud firestore our client libraries
come fully equipped to handle these use
cases
so let's talk about the data model in
firestore we've mentioned already that
firestore is a document store so at the
smallest unit the smallest unit of
storage in fire store is a document and
a document as you can see up here on the
screen is a lightweight record that
contains key value pairs
there is no schema enforcement in fire
store so you have complete freedom over
what fields you put in a document
now documents can be grouped together in
related groups that we call collections
and you can see that representation up
here documents can also map to sub
collections and this lends itself really
nicely to hierarchical data that's very
common in web and mobile app development
so what we've seen so far is that this
model works really really well for
developers and is designed really well
to scale as well so let's talk about
what's new in cloud fire store as I
mentioned cloud fire store went
generally available just earlier this
year at the end of January it was in
beta for a little over a year before
that since 2017 so as part of the
announcement of going generally
available we have some pretty cool new
things that we've announced so the first
thing I want to mention is that cloud
fire store operates in two different
modes datastore mode and native mode
these have slightly different strengths
that I will highlight based on the use
case that you're looking for so the
first thing is that datastore mode has
the exact same API in same scale as
datastore but a new storage layer so if
you are a datastore customer this one
will feel very familiar to you and in
fact eventually all existing datastore
customers will be able to upgrade to
fire store in datastore mode datastore
mode also has some new things that are
greater than some of the things offered
in datastore today and those things
include strong consistency where we had
eventually consistent queries before in
datastore
we also have a higher availability SLA
which I'll talk about in a second and we
also have a new data flow connector so
on the other side of things we have
native mode and native mode leverages
this new document model and it
integrates with third-party clients and
that's kind of the main difference and
for those of you coming from the
firebase real-time database world
it's more akin to the model there with
the direct client access a simple way to
think about this is that data store mode
is optimized and scales really really
well for your rights and native mode
scales really really well for concurrent
connections so when you're thinking
about all these different clients trying
to connect to the same application at
once as part of going generally
available we also announced ten new
regions ten new locations that are a
combination of multi region and regional
so you can see we have two new regional
sorry two new multi regional locations
that are highlighted in green we have
one in the US and one in Europe and
these multi region locations can
actually withstand the loss of entire
regions because they're duplicate and
they're replicated across more than one
and this maintains availability without
losing data and all of these regions are
actually required to be at least 100
miles apart in addition we have new
service level agreements that are
attached to each of these different
types of locations so the first for
multi region which is our highest SLA we
have five nines availability and for
regional we have four nines SOA
both of these are actually improvements
over the SLA is that you saw in
datastore which were four 9s and three
three 9s respectively and lastly you can
access firestore directly from the cloud
console many of you who come from the
real-time database world may know that
you can also access firestore from the
firebase console and that's very common
as well one of the things to note about
these UIs is that they both operate on
the same projects so if you create a
project in the cloud console it's the
same project that you'll see available
in the firebase console as well one of
the benefits of using the Google Cloud
console is that
you have access to all the other GCP
products that i mentioned including
things like bigquery and that's
something that we're actually going to
showcase later in the demo is how to get
some of the data that's in fire store
into bigquery so let's walk through a
couple of customer examples since we
went GA we've seen a huge diversity of
workloads since launch and some of these
were actually some of our early beta
customers as well back from 2017 so we
have a lot of customers that spans that
span tons of different industries but
they do have a couple of things in
common the first is that a lot of these
companies needed a really quick time to
market so they don't spend all this time
you know provisioning servers picking
things off the shelf and stacking these
together second is that they needed
something that would have the ability to
scale with their business they wanted
the same solution for their ten users
that they want for their hundred
thousand 1 million user use case and the
third thing is that a lot of these
companies had really lean development
teams and they wanted to operate in a
server less environment and as we know
firestore is a service environment you
don't have to think in terms of nodes
that you're provisioning or capacity and
resource planning in fact the pricing is
actually built on an operational model
based on the reason right so you're
actually doing against the system and
this is huge because firestore does not
require a massive team to run it and
that's the beauty of it the same team
that gets you started can actually carry
you through through the scaling of your
application the first one of these
customers that I want to highlight is a
company called Hakan dynamics they build
sophisticated hardware and software for
athletic monitoring that's used by
several professional sports teams
so this hardware that they develop
includes what you can see up here on the
screen which is wireless force plates
and these wireless force plates measure
the impact and movement of athletes and
they can track and measure the
performance of these athletes over time
by capturing this isometric data in
their application and sending it back to
fire store
here's what their architecture looks
like they have the wireless forceplates
which capture and send the data to the
hock in Dynamics mobile app this
collects information across athletes in
many locations and because their testing
facilities are often in low connectivity
areas as you can imagine fields maybe
they're you know doing something at high
altitude the ability to have this
offline sync is very very important to
them so they can do their tests capture
the data for the athletes have it sent
back to the application and then they
have coaches or other people that are
monitoring the athletic statistics
connecting from other devices like
tablets and desktop computers that can
access this information immediately so
this is very important to them and
they've actually been kind enough to
show their data model so we can drill
into a little bit of how they've
actually modeled their business using
the cloud the cloud firestore document
model so what you'll see up here is the
top-level collection called teams each
of these this collection contains
documents one of each corresponding to
each of their teams and these teams have
sub collections in these sub collections
you can see some of them listed here it
can include settings raw force data
that's collected from the force plates
different tests if we drill in a level
further they also have a sub collection
called athletes so here there's a
document for every one of the athletes
that they're collecting this information
on and here they can drill into all the
tests that have been captured or
performed for that a fleet over time the
next customer that I want to highlight
is one that you actually may be familiar
with there's a high chance that you went
to this website because you're all here
today or that you accessed the mobile
app so our developer friends over at the
nerdery
I think we have some of them potentially
in the audience there so they are a
digital consultancy that actually helped
build the conference web and mobile apps
for us using cloud firestore so they use
fire store as an aggregation hub for all
of the conference data that's serving
the session information the breakouts
etc and again we actually have
a data model to show you and see how
this works and so here you can see an
actual document that represents content
that's being served to the next home
page and in this case it's the mobile
app mobile app home page so you can see
the content being served here it also
has static content that's being stored
elsewhere and you can see the path to
that information here if I click to the
next this is actually a high-level
collection representing all of the
different next events so the one that's
highlighted right now is the one that
you're in here today for which is next
SF you'll also see entries here for the
future next events that we have in Tokyo
and London and here is actually the
session we're in right now so this
document represents the session ID you
can see here we have information about
the session type the different related
fields so these are sessions it
recommends you go to if you also have
gone to this one and then speaker IDs
which refer to both Dunn and myself
something that's not on the screen that
also exists in the app is field lower
down that tells the capacity of each of
the sessions so you can imagine that the
capacity is full it will no longer let
someone register for that so when you
first visit the conference site what
you're seeing is a session and speaker
information that's being loaded from
firestore as well as some of these
static images and assets from Google
Cloud Storage when you sign in with
either your Google Account or personal
email address you're actually hitting
firebase off which is authenticating you
and making sure you have you know the
proper account and you have access to
all the information you're seeing then
when you register for a session like
this one that you're in today the app
makes an API call out it updates the
information in fire store and
immediately updates that information to
the user so next what I want to do is
invite been on stage now that you've
seen some customer examples I want him
to actually demonstrate fire store for
you in action Thank You Natalie
[Applause]
I am Ben whitehead I'm a developer
programs engineer with Google Cloud
focusing on cloud firestore and cloud
datastore so I'm gonna be running
through a demo today showing how we've
got a demo app built leveraging the real
time functionality of cloud firestore as
well as some of the larger suite of GCP
to handle doing analytics tasks to kind
of help the business understand how your
app is behaving so first we're gonna
look at a couple of architecture
diagrams just to give a high-level view
and then we'll dig into some of the
details so here we've got a high-level
architecture diagram of the app that
we're going to be demoing and analyzing
today called fire pixels in the little
mobile icon you can kind of see that
there are four colored quadrants this is
actually the firestore logo colored
using the google colors so each of these
respective quadrants is made up of
10,000 pixels and each of those 10,000
pixels are backed by a document in fire
store so in fire store we actually have
a document for every single pixel that's
maintaining the color of that pixel the
last updated timestamp as well as a
partition that we're using to paralyze
the events propagating to the UI that
we'll be able to see in the real-time
demo in just a few minutes so given that
there are the four quadrants each of
them have 10,000 this can handle up to
40,000 concurrent users essentially kind
of poking at the bits to represent each
of the pixels so we've got a simulation
service running on gke that's actually
running a simulation of some user
activity so you will be seeing pixels
kind of updating when we get over to the
demo so we've got this application up
and running we've gained a fair amount
of user traction and the business comes
over to us and says great you've got
this thing we need to start we need to
start getting some numbers and because
you were very quick to market that
probably didn't mean that you baked all
of your analytics into your app from the
get-go so how do you kind of reinforce
and get information for your users so
the particular business questions that
we're going to be answering today are
the number of event of distinct color
events that have happened over the past
30 minutes over the past two days and
over the past seven days
the next question is what are the number
of distinct colors that occurred in the
last minute for the past 30 minutes and
finally we're going to have a chart that
we are going to use to monitor the
ingestion latency of how long it's
actually taking to process these events
from user actions to it being available
in the data warehouse so this is a
high-level architecture diagram
essentially expanding on what components
were going to be looking at today so on
the left-hand side the yellow box that's
a little faint sorry about that
the left-hand box represents the same
slide that we just saw previously so we
can see here cloud firestore is sort of
the bridging point into the rest of GCP
that we're going to be integrating with
today and we're going to specifically be
using cloud functions to monitor change
events on each of the pixel documents
inside the database when each of those
events is triggered we're going to
handle handle that event process it and
feed that into bigquery that will then
be used to generate some predefined
views to feed charts inside data studio
so that we can put up a dashboard in our
office for everybody able to look at and
since cloud functions are these kind of
magic ephemeral things we need to have
some monitoring for us so we're going to
leverage stackdriver to do essentially
metrics monitoring and invocations per
second and those sorts of things over
time can we switch to the demo laptop
please okay great
over here on the left hand side this is
the fire pixels app this is a real-time
app this is running hitting firestore we
can see each of the four colored
quadrants currently have colors oh look
cool our simulation just kicked in that
bottom left quadrant was updated and
we've got a number of document listeners
on the back end that are listening for
those simulation
events so that was just 10,000 rights to
the database and the events being
triggered audited sent to the back end
as well as aggregated and then sent down
to the web client over WebSockets so
it's very responsive it can give you a
great experience for your users and will
be able to kind of see that changing
over time during the rest of the
presentation so first we're going to
jump over to a cloud fire store in the
Google console and we're going to take a
look into the the data model that's
actually backing the fire pixels app
right now on the left hand side so here
on the left hand column we've got three
different collections top-level
collections one for devices one for
input and one for pixels the collection
for devices this is actually a heartbeat
collection so for each of the respective
clients that are managing each of those
pixels as part of the simulation we're
essentially tracking the heartbeat of
the last time one of those users
actually did something for us if we move
down to the inputs collection we can see
a zero through three the zero through
three here represent each of the colored
quadrants over on the left-hand side
starting top to bottom left to right
excuse me
left to right top to bottom so zero one
two three in each of those documents we
can see the color we can also see the
updated timestamp of the last time that
quadrant was updated and if we look at
the pixels collection here we can see a
list of the 40,000 documents that
represent each of the pixels so the the
name of the document that we've got here
is essentially three digits - three
digits this was representing the XY
coordinate in the in the grid and we can
see the color for that particular pixel
which partition that pixel is associated
with and the last updated timestamp so
while the the simulation is running wow
we got it all blue that's really unusual
let's take the top right and let's
change this to be yellow so I can hit
that that's going to trigger the events
all the event handlers on the back side
are going to observe that particular
part of the simulation they're then
going to update each of those
affective pixel documents and then again
that's going to be aggregated to the
back end and sent over to the to the UI
so you can kind of see like how quick
and responsive that is even from like an
administrative standpoint from there
let's jump back over to the Google Cloud
console a quick overview here the Google
Cloud console is trying to help you out
and kind of surface information that's
relevant to you based on how your
project is behaving so for our project
we are using compute engine to run our
gke cluster for our simulations we've
got some GCS buckets Google Cloud
Storage buckets for storing some static
assets we can also see that we're using
cloud functions we currently have one
function that's deployed and we've got
one data set in bigquery which is
ultimately the data warehouse data set
that we're going to be working with
today and we can also see a quick
overview of a number API requests as
well as compute engine CPU processing
the API requests this is aggregated
across all of the various back-end
products in GCP so this can give you a
kind of a good idea of how much of GCP
are using without necessarily having to
build up a big graph all yourself so for
here let's start from cloud functions so
I'm gonna open it up in a new tab real
quick this is the single cloud function
that we have active right now if you had
more cloud functions they would show up
in this list you get a quick overview
what region the function is running in
you know this is important for data
locality just in terms of latency of
processing it's also becoming
increasingly more important due to
regulatory restrictions around data
egress and and migrations and those
sorts of things the trigger type of the
function so there are many types of
triggers that you can use with cloud
functions today we're using cloud fire
store you could also use it with Google
Cloud storage when a new document is
created or other sorts of things like
that's where for this example we're
using node.js version 8 this is
convenient gives us the async/await
handles so it makes our code a little
bit more terse which is nice I've given
this function blindly 256 megabytes of
Ram I seriously doubt I'm using that
much so I should probably knock it down
to save on some billing but you know I
haven't been harassed about that yet so
we'll worry about it later and then the
function inside our code that's going to
be called as part of the event handler
is called on pixel change and we can see
the last time that this code was
deployed so I was clicking here and load
up some of the details when we click
into each of the functions we get a
high-level overview showing the number
of invocations per second where we can
kind of see success failure error rates
those sorts of things just in a
high-level view this little peak that we
notice on the right-hand side this is
when I manually change the value in the
database a couple of minutes ago and
those events got kind of processed
immediately so that's higher than the
normal simulation is normally doing you
can see that you can kind of get some
different time granularities but
ultimately this information is sort of
bounded to what time what time
boundaries you have here
so for longer-term storage and
monitoring and alerting will leverage
stackdriver for that and we'll get to
that in just a minute so scrolling down
a little bit one thing that's not shown
on the summary page is this service
account down here the service account is
actually very important so the service
account gives your function and identity
as far as access controls and security
are concerned in the greater GCP so when
I'm integrating with bigquery the
identity of next i/o storage service
account is given the permission to write
into bigquery so if you've got many
projects or many teams you can do
fine-grained controls to where you could
say like this function is able to write
to this thing in bigquery but this other
function is only able to interact with
GCS so it gives you that kind of control
to be able to handle multiple things at
the same time so jumping over here to
the trigger and we saw the trigger type
earlier as cloud store or caught fire
store the particular event type that
we're carrying about right now is update
there's also the create and delete as
well as just general right so this can
be really nice from like an auditing
standpoint or do
data ingestion for analytics as we're
doing today without having to do
modifications to your database or to
your app you can essentially hook up
monitoring those sorts of things and
then the resource path right here so if
you remember back here in firestore
we've got our pixels collection if you
think of this as sort of like a
directory structure that matches with
the document collection sub collection
document sort of pattern right now
essentially I'm specifying like a
directory structure that says underneath
the patterns are the pixels collection I
want to match on any pixel so inside
curly braces essentially like a variable
placeholder so over here on the source
tab for folks so this massive 30 lines
of code is the sum total of code that
you need to be able to get an event from
the cloud function into bigquery
so the bigquery node module were able to
just import up here the data set that
we're inserting to the table that we're
inserting to and we're creating the
bigquery client right here on line 5
you'll notice there's no credential
passing or hey load up this thing or
anything like that
the default constructor for the clients
is defaulted to using the service
account so if you're running something
on cloud functions or you're running
something on App Engine or GCP the
environment is essentially bootstrap for
you already to use the service account
information that you've configured
through the cloud API so moving down a
little bit lines 7 through 26 or the
full function at line 8 and 9 we're
essentially pulling out the time 0
values and then on line 9 we're pulling
out the time 1 values and then we're
constructing our data structure that we
want to send to bigquery so that's the
pixel that's being modified essentially
the pre and post values as well as the
process time when this is actually being
processed and sent it to bigquery then
on line 21 is where we're doing natural
write to bigquery and our function is
effectively done we do have a console
log statement here
I should have cleaned this up it's not
actually doing anything useful for us at
this point but the logs that I write to
the console here are actually available
in stackdriver
so if you're setting up your function
and you're like hey did I actually get
the data there or and kind of curious
what the events look like that sort of
stuff
you can do your kind of printf
console.log inspection and all that
information shows up and stackdriver
okay so jumping back to the cloud
console real quick
from here pardon me I actually skipped
stackdriver
so let's let's pull up stackdriver first
so stackdriver if if folks aren't
familiar is the kind of monitoring user
site monitoring hub for your apps and
usage of GCP on GCP so here we can see
essentially a metric graph it looks very
similar to the overview excuse me the
overview that we had back on the
function page but it does give you the
ability to do broader time spans so we
can actually look back and see the
development work that picked up in the
middle of the may for this particular
demo you can even do custom time frames
if you wanted to as well as real-time
dashboards if this is something that you
want to kind of put in your your team's
bullpen or something like that so let's
jump back down to an hour so right now
we've got three different charts so
we're tracking the number of executions
of our cloud function per second in the
case of stackdriver this is being
aggregated up to permanent buckets so we
can see over time again that little peak
when I manually change the database
scrolling down we can see the cloud
function instance counts so this is one
of the things that's really powerful
about cloud functions is it essentially
it takes care of all of the scaling
factors for you so by us triggering
events and events being in queued to be
processed GCP figures out how many
functions it needs to scale up for you
and when they can able be able to scale
down and back up and those sorts of
things so that's why you're seeing some
kind of like spike eNOS is when it's
scaling down it's trying to save me
money when it's scaling back up
giving it more work to do the final
chart down at the bottom is a pretty
cool little chart the stackdriver
provides which gives you a heat map so
instead of having to look at your like
seven lines for your p 50 and p 95 and
all that stuff it'll actually just
render a heat graph for you so we can
see here that most of our events are
processing in about 100 milliseconds
this little hot spot down here when I
did the manual trigger again but this is
nice because you can kind of start to
see things over time if we were to
expand this to the last week we can see
that it's been running relatively
consistent we've had a couple high
latency pokes at a couple different
point in times but you know nothing
super concerning as they've kind of come
back down it looks like our peaks or
about five seconds or so so jumping back
to the cloud console from here we're
going to jump into bigquery and take a
look at the data set so this is the
schema of the pixel tables you notice it
looks exactly like the JSON document
that we look like looked at in the
function unlike firestore bigquery is
schema but this is to help out with
query planning and just kind of the
dynamic nature and analytics and the
fact that it's SQL oriented so we click
on preview we can actually see a summary
of some of the data that's in there so 4
pixels 66 comma 103 we changed from red
to blue partition stay the time and then
we've got the respective time stamps
this all supports kind of your standard
SQL that you're familiar with so I could
do like select star from the cog console
Esso has nice auto completion for you
which is really great because inevitably
you end up getting kind of long names
and historical names and all that stuff
let's see order by
t-1 updated descending limit and we can
it go and it'll essentially just start
crunching so in our full database so far
we've got something like 600 million
events that have been stuck in our data
warehouse and that's in the span of
about two weeks so as as apps get more
sort of IOT and user intensive you can
imagine like just having a database that
can scale out and give you quick queries
is is really valuable and that's what
we're getting from bigquery so we're
gonna jump down here and look at a view
real quick
so the views that we've got defined here
are essentially what we're using to
drive the charts that I'll show you in
just a second you can see that they're
kind of standard SQL you know select
from table group by ordering limits all
that same normal stuff so you're not
having to learn a brand new like
charting library or anything like that
you can just write your SQL statements
and then load that up in your dashboard
so we'll jump over here to the fire
pixels dashboard so this is a dashboard
that I've created in data studio one of
the things that's really nice about data
studio dashboards is it fully integrates
with all of your G suite organization
structure so this dashboard that I'm
showing you right now is actually shared
to my demo user from my main work user
so this is really nice if you need to
like put it on a display in your bullpen
or if you only want to share it with
maybe your manager before it's published
to the rest of the company you've got
full ACL control the same way that you
do with Google Docs so here on the top
row we can see three different charts
with color breakdowns
so these color breakdowns are answering
the questions that we mentioned kind of
at the beginning of the demo around the
business questions so the business
question is essentially how many or
excuse me for the top row is what is the
ratio of a particular color per time
bucket over a period of time so here
we're seeing for the last 30 minutes
about 63% of the color changes were to
blue and the other 37 or so were to
yellow so this makes it really easy to
kind of look at the charts and having
some context around the way that the app
behaves you can just kind of look at it
and get an idea of what the app probably
looked like at that point in time and
then that expands to two days ago as
well as over the past week in the bottom
left we've got our line chart that's
showing the number of distinct colors
that were changed to in that time frame
so here we can see that we had two that
we changed to one time we only had one
one time we actually got all the way up
to three you know just various
interesting things and then the center
chart is showing our ingestion latency
so this is the essentially showing in
seconds how long it's taking from the
document being written into firestore
for us to write it into bigquery so this
is essentially showing us an end-to-end
latency of getting data into our data
warehouse so the vast majority are being
handled in less than two seconds and
we've got a little bit of a kind of
plateau here this is actually I believe
due to the fact that the cloud functions
are spinning back up after being spun
down between stages of the simulation
running and then there's almost a full
drop off by the time we reach seven
seconds so the vast vast majority of all
of our events are being put into our
data warehouse in eight seconds or so
[Music]